[Musique]
les marins shadoks sont partis en bateau
dans le cosmos pour conquérir la planète
jbe voyons un peu où ils en sont eh bien
il ramait sous le commandement de
principe du pirate shadoks qui comme à
l'ordinaire était assez joliment a pris
de boisson
[Musique]
si bien que personne en fait ne regarder
où on allait mais il disait il dans la
marine c'est l usage et qu'il est
beaucoup plus intéressant de regarder où
l'on ne va pas pour la bonne raison que
là où l'on va il sera toujours temps d'y
regarder quand on y sera et que de toute
façon ça ne sera jamais en fin de compte
que de l'eau sauf naturellement prévu or
un jour justement un marin s'écria plus
doux c'était vrai il ne pouvait plus
avancer
le marin shadoks avait observé que l'eau
à l'avant des bateaux avaient souvent
tendance à se transformer subitement
iceberg en cailloux en baleine ou même
en rien du tout mais il avait remarqué
aussi car l'arrière des bateaux il y
avait toujours de l'eau qui ne servait à
rien et pour continuer d'avancer il
ordonna que l'on récupère cette eau là
pour la mettre à l'avant de sorte que
pendant que des shadoks d'en haut
ramé long ceux d'en bas la récupérer
pour que se donneront la rame
c'était un système de navigation
ingénieux mais épuisant et
pouvait se demander si les valeureux
marins pourraient aller comme ça jusqu'à
l'autre bout du cosmos
[Musique]